Wayne Brady is a pansexual what's a
pansexual I don't know so there's no
pants though he's washing a dish
[Music]
[Applause]
there's some guy there some gal there
some rainbow flag dude
and Brady with a nice Pink Suit
okay so that that's his video and he
comes out and says in this post this is
the text of his post he goes as someone
who gets to bring joy to others daily on
TV it's been ironic that I don't
experience it as much as I'd like I
advocate mental health for all and a
part of that is self-transparency and
doing my work I've come to see a few
truths one of them being that I want to
be free to love whomever I want this
truth makes me pan and part of the lgbtq
family